-Welcome back, everybody. We're
hanging out with Katie Holmes!
She stars in the new play
"The Wanderers,"
which begins previews
January 26th.
Now, Katie,
when you're acting in a play,
there's usually --
backstage before the show,
you do some vocal
exercises and practice,
so I thought we'd have a fun
game and put your skills
to the test in a new game
we call "Fast Talkers."
Here we go.
-♪ Fast Talkers ♪
♪ Talking so fast,
Fast Talkers ♪
-Now, here's how this works.
We're going to draw a card
from this pile, okay?
Each one has
a tongue twister on it.
And we're gonna have to say
the tongue twister
as many times as we can
in 10 seconds.
Whoever says it
the most times, wins.
You ready for this?
-Okay.
-Alright.
-Wait.
Do we do it at the same time?
-No.
-Okay. Got it.
-Do you wanna?
-You go first.
-Okay. Alright.
Oh, okay, alright.
So we have to say it.
But I'll go first.
I have to say, "Who do you think
is in Hoobastank?"
As many times as I can
in 10 seconds.
Alright.
10 seconds on the clock.
-You got it.
-I'm gonna go for it.
-Do it.
-Ready?
Who do you think
is in Hoobastank?
[ Buzzer ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
[ Laughter ]
-You okay?
[ Applause ]
-Thank you so much.
Thank you. Wow.
I didn't think that was gonna
take that much out of me.
Okay.
-How many was that?
-I don't know. How many
was that, for the record?
12! That's amazing!
I can't say the word "amazing"
that many times in 10 seconds.
Alright.
Katie Holmes, here's your
first tongue twister.
Whenever you're ready.
-Go?
-Once you start, we'll start.
-Oh, okay.
-Who do you think
is in Hoobastank?
Who do you think
[ Buzzer ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
Was that wrong?
-No.
At one point --
I don't know if it was right.
It was so good.
But at one point you're like --
[ Speaking incoherently ]
I wanted to be like, "Who was
there eating the tuba steak?"
Alright.
How many did Katie get there?
11! Oh, my gosh.
Ooh, it's a game.
It's a game.
-Oh, my. Okay.
-It's a game.
-Okay.
-Alright, now it's a game.
Here we go.
I'll take the win
on that first one.
Alright. The second one
is now a longer tongue twister.
We can see how many times
we can say this in 10 seconds.
-You're really good at this.
-This is -- Thank you.
[ Laughter ]
Can I turn this into a talent?
I don't know what -- There's
got to be money to be made.
Alright, this one is,
"Did you see Taylor Swift
hop off a ski lift?"
[ Laughter ]
Alright. 10 seconds
on the clock. Here we go.
Did you see Taylor Swift
hop off a ski lift?
[ Laughter ]
Hop off a ski lift?
Did you see Taylor Swift
hop off a ski lift?
Did you see Taylor Swift --
[ Buzzer ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
I started sounding weird.
Like, I started saying,
"Hah-pahf."
"Did you see Taylor Swift
hah-pahf?"
-"Hah-hah-hah-pahf."
-"Did you see Taylor swift
hah-pahf?"
How many did I get?
-I thought it was a choice.
-You thought it was a choice?
No, it wasn't.
6?
-Alright.
-This one's a toughie.
Alright. Good luck to you.
-Thank you.
-Yeah. You're welcome.
-Ready?
-Mm-hmm.
-Did you see Taylor Swift
hop off a ski lift?
Did you see Taylor Sqwift --
[ Laughter ]
Hop off a T -- a ski lift?
Did you see Taylor Swift
hop off a ski lift?
Five. That was only five.
-I think that was good.
Actually we should
give her one there, too,
'cause I think we started
a little late there.
Can we give -- I think
we give a bonus one to --
Yeah? I think it's a tie.
-Really?
-I think.
Judges?
-Yeah!
[ Bell dings ]
-Yeah.
-Alright.
-Yeah, we started a little
early. That was great.
-You're invited
to Thanksgiving now.
-But this next one,
this last one...
-Okay.
-...is worth 10,000 points.
Whoever gets this...
-Alright. Okay.
-...has bragging rights
of the fastest talker.
-Alright, okay.
-Whew. 10 seconds on the clock.
I have to say...
"Megan won the Mega Millions,
which is major cuz it means
she's makin' bacon."
[ Laughter ]
Let's get 10 seconds
on the clock. Here we go.
Megan won the Mega Millions
which is major cuz it means
she's makin' bacon.
Megan won the Mega Millions
which is major cuz it means
she's makin' bacon.
Megan won the Mega Millions
which is major cuz it means
she's makin' bacon.
Megan won the Mega Millions
which is major cuz it means
she's makin' bacon.
Megan won the Mega Millions
which is major cuz it means
she's makin' bacon.
[ Buzzer ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Wow!
-I'm acting like
it's something --
-Are you gonna do...
-I don't know what I was doing.
Why would I be so impressed
with myself on that?
-I mean, that was good.
-There's nothing to be
bragging about at all.
-You're good.
-How many did I get on that one?
Five!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Alright, so the pressure's on.
Do you want to practice one?
-Megan won the Mega Millions
which is major cuz it means
she's makin' bacon.
-Okay.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Whenever you start, we'll start.
-Megan won the Mega Millions
which is major cuz it means
she's makin' bacon.
Megan won the Mega Millions
which is major cuz it means
she's makin' bacon.
Megan won the Mega Millions
which is major cuz it means
she's makin' bacon.
Megan won the Mega Millions
which is major cuz it means
she's makin' bacon.
Megan won the Mega Millions
which is major cuz it means
she's makin' bacon.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Judges?!
-That's a tie!
-Judges?
-It's a tie!
-That's a tie.
-I think it's a tie.
I'll give the win
to Katie Holmes.
Come on. Katie Holmes!
"The Wanderers"
begins previews January 26th
and opens February 16th.
We'll be right back with more
"Tonight Show," everybody.
Come on back.